[Music]
thank you
[Music]
coming up on FYI we quiz the politicians
in charge of our education will there be
more free School meals and how do they
plan to stop our teachers striking
[Music]
and find out what happened when young 40
funds took over the Sky Sports
commentary of a Premier League football
match
[Music]
happy New Year and welcome back to FYI
the Weekly News show where we bring you
all the latest info on all the big
stories so as we headed back to school
you may have seen some stories about
teachers threatening to go on strike
over their salaries and demands for more
free School meals as family struggle due
to Rising costs well our schools and how
good they are is down to the decisions
made by the politicians in charge we are
two senior politicians Who oversee our
education to take our questions they
agreed here's jariah and Scarlett with
an exclusive report for FYI
[Music]
these two women have one thing in common
they want to make our scores and
education better
one has the power to make the changes
the other wants her job
this is Jillian Keegan
she is a member of the conservative
political party which is in government
and Jillian is in charge of our
education in England other parts of the
UK have their own education ministers
and this is Bridget Phillipson she is a
member of the second largest political
party labor and they want to win the
next election to become our next
government a shadow education secretary
it's her job to hold Jillian to account
there's been no action to support
families why not we have actually taken
a lot of action in this area
one of the biggest issues facing pupils
right now is the rising cost of everyday
needs millions of families are
struggling to pay the bills and buy food
yet in England only certain pupils are
allowed free school dinners
there's been growing demand for free
School meals for all so why isn't the
government doing that so if you gave it
for everybody then that means a lot of
people who don't need it would get it
what you're trying to do is make sure it
gets to the most disadvantaged people
and then the other thing that we put in
was free School meals for all infants
and now we've just put in breakfasts in
those areas that are more deprived
Scotland and Wales are Miles Ahead of
England in getting free School meals so
when are we going to follow their lead I
mean do you think we'll follow their
lead no because they're doing it for
everybody so that gets back to people
who don't need it does that mean you
won't be able to do something else but
what did the shadow education secretary
think what we've said right now is that
we would make sure that every Primary
School child in England has access to a
breakfast club because we know that it's
a real concern that lots of children are
arriving at school not ready to learn
because they haven't had a good start to
the day but just as important you know
as breakfast is doesn't it just seem
like you're willing to pay for the
cheapest option I know that even if I
had breakfast in stores starving by
lunchtime and that just doesn't make
sense surely you should pay for every
child's School meals I would love to be
in a position to to do more on this but
as you'll know obviously we're in a very
difficult situation right now as a
country where it comes to the economy
and I'm only able to commit to things
where I'm absolutely confident about how
we're going to pay for that and right
now because the economy is in such
difficult position it's really hard to
make you know those kinds of commitments
right now
Adventures for all pupils in England
but they are for younger children and
there will be funding for more breakfast
clubs for all people's in deprived areas
and if labor was in government they
wouldn't provide free school lunches for
All Peoples either
instead they would introduce free
breakfast for all pupils which is
cheaper
in the last few days the Prime Minister
announced that he wants us all to study
maths until we're 18 years old but what
about new subjects many of you have
written to FYI complaining that the
lessons we get at school have hardly
changed since our parents were in the
classroom
I know that me and jaria and loads of my
friends would love to learn about other
things like climate change and maybe
finances our world is changing so why
isn't our curriculum changing too well
the curriculum has changed actually
um a fair bit we are introducing a new
GCSE which is something we agreed to do
at cop 26 when we hosted the climate
change conference here which is natural
history there are I mean geography as
well the curriculums you know obviously
develop quite a lot to look at impacts
and impacts of of climate change we put
the same question to the shadow
education secretary I do think our
curriculum needs to be reviewed and I
think it is important that it reflects
the needs and wishes of young people
right now but also in a bigger sense
about what young people will need to
learn for later in life as well so do
you think you would consider changing
like the curriculums being a black boy
myself learning more about black history
and more than slave trade we're always
looking to improve and make sure that
people learn more about each other so
they're more tolerant of other people's
views I would want to make sure that
we've got a broad and balanced
curriculum and but also a really
enriching curriculum where young people
get opportunities to really develop as
individuals
stuff living hits families t utors are
among a growing number of workers asking
asking to wages
government offer of a five percent rise
has been rejected
now teachers across the country are
threatening to strike basically refusing
to go to work on certain days what are
you willing to do to stop articles from
being closed down by teacher strikes I
really don't want schools to close
through strikes I know that you know all
of you have missed out on a lot of your
education because of covert that's why a
fiber education secretary I'd be
absolutely determined to try and get a
compromise we're going to pay the
teachers a rise which is between five
and eight point nine percent and it is
seen to be the fair approach well do you
think you'd give them more than what the
current government is offering a five
percent I mean they work so hard they
deserve more than five percent labor
from government last time around we made
sure that all of our staff in our
schools were getting a good pay deal so
that's teachers and support staff too
you know I know they worked really hard
during the pandemic in the field that
the government didn't recognize their
contribution do you think that teachers
deserve a need a 12 pay rise I think
teachers are absolutely right to argue
for a pay rise because they pay year on
year over these last 12 years has gone
down
the rising cost of living
and may go on strike soon if they don't
get it but the government seemed to be
standing firm on a rise of between five
and eight point nine percent
couldn't pin down the shadow education
secretary on a figure she thinks
teachers should be offered
well thank you so much for speaking to
us we really appreciate your time it's
been wonderful to meet you too thank you
[Music]
teachers in Scotland have already stayed
strikes over their salaries and schools
were forced to close now teaches in
other parts of the UK are about to
decide whether they will go on strike
too but is it fair for teachers to go on
strike and force our schools to close
well it's time to get your shout on this
we're headed to Barnet in North London
the second largest London borough to
hear from an FYI News Club at Southgate
School
I don't think politicians are really
focused on improving pay for teachers
I'm sure that if they were a teacher
they'll probably like really want like
higher pay or something yeah that's I
think teachers should get paid like the
same as doctors because doctors they're
saving lives but teachers they're kind
of building on someone's life they do a
lot to support you know students and
make sure they have like a good
education and do well in the future and
I think that should maybe be recognized
a bit more for like the interests of the
students should be more important to the
teacher than money then again it is
their job
so they need to make a living wage
imagine you're getting a job and you're
not getting paid what you think you
should then that's a problem strikes or
a drastic measure but they work in some
cases
and so if people aren't being paid
enough for their job they have the right
to strike they have the right to demand
more money I don't think it's fair that
they're going to go on strike because
then that rooms are learning times I
feel like it's a very selfish thing to
do in my opinion I think there's better
ways
um right then maybe protests but strike
is a protest isn't it a strike is a way
to grab potentially by saying I'm not
going to do this job until you pay me
more and the government needs these
teachers to work I don't believe there's
enough teachers in certain areas and so
if they go on strike the government will
have no choice but to pay them more
check out this story that we spotted but
is it fake news or fact this British
Island apparently celebrates Christmas
12 days after the rest of the world
residents of this remote island near
Scotland celebrate Christmas Day on the
6th of January a New Year's Day on
January 13th but is this fake or fact
find out later on
[Music]
so have you guys made a New Year's
resolution to be healthier and eat more
vegetables have you well I'm sure my mum
would like me to well there's one
vegetable that you might be happy to see
the back of after Christmas and that's
the Brussels sprout what's your opinion
on them Freedom if I'm going to be
honest with you I think they're not very
nice they're bitter and they're kind of
like a snooker ball so I'm not a fan
well I can happily say that I disagree
with Braden and I love brussels sprouts
but why is it that so many of us hate
brussels sprouts but our parents love
them well we're going to ask an expert
we're joined by Rosemary Collier who's a
researcher at Warwick University and
she's been looking into the sites behind
why we either love or hate brussels
sprouts hi Rosemary hello
so we've actually read that there's an
area in the UK used for growing brussels
sprouts that's the equivalent to
3240 football pitches I mean that's a
lot why are we growing so many when they
just don't taste good well one of the
reasons why they don't taste very good
is due to a chemical that they contain
that makes them taste bitter and in fact
about half of the population can detect
that bitter taste and the other half of
the population don't so maybe you're in
the part of the population that they do
taste bitter so why is it that so many
of us hate brussels sprouts but our
parents love them there's some evidence
that your taste buds change as you grow
older and that young people children are
particularly sensitive to the bitter
taste so as you grow older you probably
get to like brussels sprouts more so are
they really that good for us they're
very good indeed for you they're full of
vitamins and minerals and they contain
as much vitamin C as oranges though it's
good to know that they're good for you
then so thank you so much for your time
Rosemary you're very welcome
[Music]
so have you seen this wandering walrus
this big fella nicknamed Thor attracted
a crowd of thousands when he popped up
in Scarborough and this guy actually led
to the new year fireworks being canceled
he then swam more than 70 miles north
and was spotted in a harbor in
Northumberland it's hoped he's making
his way back to where he should be which
is in the Arctic experts say he is
healthy and he just wanted to take a
wander down the English coastline
now do you fancy shark spotting from the
comfort of your own home you heard me
right because volunteers are being
recruited to identify sharks skates and
Rays from underwater cameras around the
coast of Wales data from hours of
footage needs to be logged to help
researchers identify the different types
of species and hopefully get the
clearest picture yet of what's at the
bottom of the sea and check this out so
the Natural History Museum actually
announced that they discovered
351 species in 2022 a huge range of
plants and animals have been named from
Moss animals and dinosaurs to stick
insects and minerals and an impressive
85 new species of wasps have been
discovered
now most of us have probably watched a
Premier League game in the stadium or
even on TV right but wouldn't it be
great to get that little bit closer to
the action maybe even take over all the
coverage replace the reporters and even
the commentators and thanks to Sky
Sports that's exactly what just happened
[Music]
hi I'm Delilah at Brentford vs Liverpool
but this isn't any ordinary football
game come with me as I go behind the
scenes
foreign
[Music]
for this special coverage of the match
host Kelly Cates is joined by Young fans
from each team to join in with the
reporting interviewing and even
commentating
let's do this
[Music]
you're from Denmark can you teach us how
to say goal in Danish okay I can try
gold is
Premier League Juniors is all about
getting young people from across the
country involved in football and maybe
even finding some future Sky Sports
pundits first presenters I've ever
worked with that was amazing
so Delilah can you see yourself going
into football commentating when you're
older I'd probably want to play football
a bit first but then after a while I'd
probably uh maybe take up doing a bit of
commentating so how was the atmosphere
inside the stadium uh well first of all
it was loud and the atmosphere was
pretty exciting but there was a little
bit of tension in there as well well it
sounds like a good day overall yeah
definitely I I never got the opportunity
to do that before so I was very grateful
when I got told it and I was just so
excited well thank you so much for your
time Delilah and we'll be seeing you
soon probably yeah see you later bye bye
so did you think it was fake or fact
that this British Island celebrates
Christmas 12 days after the rest of the
world it's a fact the tiny island of
FILA of the coast of Scotland is only
three and a half miles long and home to
just 28 people
they follow an ancient calendar which
means Christmas Day is celebrated on the
6th of January and New Year's Day is on
the 13th
for more info on how to spot fake news
head to our webpage and check out our I
don't get to explainer
and there's also details of how to get
in touch with us if you want to report
for FYI on your story even better get
your school to set up an FYI News Club
more details of how on first.news
forward slash FYI see you next time bye